mardi à 18h15 sur public sénat bienvenue
sur les chaînes parlementaires seller de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec quatre
guides r bonjour catllar toujours
michael est dans l'actualité pour ceux
qui en doutaient encore le match sarkozy
fillon est définitivement lancée le 1er
aucun non lieu de la justice dans
l'affairé bettencourt et voit donc le
ciel se dégageait le second est à
l'offensive dans la presse l'ancien
premier ministre prône la rupture
six mois de travail et 55 heures
d'audition à l'assemblée la commission
d' enquête parlementaire a rendu ses
conclusions sur la sphère cahuzac une
mascarade pour l'ump qui existent clic
estime que beaucoup de questions sont
restées sans réponse le rapport soit
rendu public la semaine prochaine
et puis vous en rappelez certainement en
mai dernier sortait sur vos écrans le
film le pouvoir une plongée dans les
coulisses de l'elysée
le dvd sort cette semaine avec des bonus
le plus de l'hebdo vous emmène à la
découverte de ces scènes inédites et
notre invité roger karoutchi bonjour
ancien ministre sénateur ump des
hauts-de-seine vice président de l'ump
et proche de nicolas sarkozy alors avant
de revoir la semaine politique avec vous
écoutez ce que pensent certains de vos
collègues
verbatim au micro de hugo l'énarque et
rodolphe zéro écouter sympathique
incisif et puis très présent et
spontanément et j'irai sarkozyste
sarkozistan quand sarkozy est toujours
tenace fidèles travailleurs dynamisme
intelligence et sens de l'humour
j'ai qu'une aucune connaissance visuelle
et auditive de lui c'est déjà pas mal
jusqu'au bout je sais pas jusqu'au bout
de quoi mais je un jour top tôt on dit
ça comme ça on a l'impression vous savez
qu'elle est ultra du temps du retour de
louis xviii
ce pot du tout le problème le problème
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qui sera
déterminant pour faire gagner la droite
et le centre
en 2017 alors c'est loin
il faut du temps et il faut rester
extrêmement calme et s'occuper d'abord
des élections municipales etc
moi je considère qu'à terre peut-être
que je me trouve
mais après tout le débat est ouvert je
considère qu'à terme celui qui sera le
meilleur fédérateur de la vente et du
centre si vous voulez un candidat unique
aux élections présidentielles entre d'un
côté le front national et de l'autre
côté françois hollande c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui peut le mieux le plus
assemblée dans ces conditions je suis
favorable au retour voilà c'est pas
c'est pas le messrs un jour dont il a
toujours fait ça mais sarkozy
vous savez je vais vous dire quelque
chose de peu que je le peux je lui ai
dit à plusieurs reprises je peux pas
dire que j'ai été commandé à l'est le
plus gâté le mieux traité sous le mandat
précédent par rapport à d'autres
ministres qui aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement critiques mais le problème
c'est pas uniquement mon sort personnel
s'est pas uniquement est-ce que j'ai été
couverts d'or d'argent et de pouvoir et
donc est ce que je lui dois tout c'est
pas ça le souci c'est de se dire est ce
que je considère comme mon corps
politique a des choses à dire à une
vraie chance de revenir à une capacité à
jouer l'alternance
et puis après on choisit voilà ce qu'à
votre jeu vous proposer une petite image
après on va revenir sur toute
l'actualité 1 c'était votre première
attaque
lyon dans un hémicycle c'était en 2000
en mai 2000 très précisément vous avez
été élu sénateur en 99
vous voyez sur ces images 13 ans après
j'ai la même tête
ouais à part l'expérience qu'est ce qui
a fondamentalement changé cheyrou et
costumes non qu'est ce qui a changé
qu'est ce qui a changé forcément le
travail parlementaire vous vous fier de
la maturité vous fier des connaissances
vous fait acquérir pour moi en tout cas
le respect des autres c'est à dire que
je l'avais déjà pas très fort on l'a
toujours considéré que j'étais trop
consensuel trop aimable pas assez dur on
dit incisif oui et jamais agressif je
n'ai jamais moi ni insulter les gens ni
considéré que l'injure était un élément
du débat public
non je pense que c'est plus de maturité
plus de réflexion sur la situation
réelle du pays
et puis une espèce de sérénité peut-être
la sérénité des sénateurs en tout cas la
sérénité qui consiste à dire j'ai eu
beaucoup de fonctions pas les plus
élevés de la république et je ne me
prétends pas mais en même temps capacité
d'analysé une capacité d'organisation
qui sont peut être reconnu et très utile
pour ceux que je servirai allez roger
karoutchi on va attaquer ce début de
semaine on parle évidemment de nicolas
sarkozy mais pas seulement
l'ancien président de la république a
donc bénéficié d'un non lieu dans la
sphère bettencourt et de son côté
l'ancien premier ministre françois
fillon
mais l'offensive dans les médias à la
une du journal du dimanche à la une de
valeur actuelle de tout résumer par
germain entre yves évidemment il va
casser un peu de vaisselle après son
avertissement dimanche dernier françois
fillon met les pieds dans le plat dans
valeurs actuelles
un long entretien et surtout une
déclaration de guerre
l'ancien premier ministre vise
directement nicolas sarkozy
il estime être mieux placé que lui pour
l'emporter en 2017
pas question non plus de minorer les
chèques en mai 2012
quand on perd une élection on doit se
remettre en cause
sinon c'est un bras d'honneur aux
français des propos en partie démenties
par les fillonnistes mais la rupture est
clair et assumé ne sont pas des propos
violents françois fillon dit simplement
qu'il se sent bien placé pour la
présidentielle 2017
il se sent bien placés en tout cas pour
la primaire qui aura lieu mais il a bien
le droit de se sentir
effectivement en bonne position c'est
son droit le plus absolu
je vois pas comment on peut lui
contester le fait que les sondages lui
donnant effectivement cette position ils
puissent lui reconnaître qu'il est bien
placé lui aussi en tête dans les
sondages
alain juppé a lancé sur son blog un
nouveau signal d' alerte
c'est la guerre des chefs continue c'est
l'existence même de l'ump qui est
menacée si on continue ainsi à tirer
dans tous les sens
c'est plus de la vaisselle cassée c'est
d éléphant dans un magasin de porcelaine
et et à terme oui
je pense que ça pourrait nous mener à
l'éclatement de l'ump 2017 c'est une
chose et si on est tous morts avant ça
ne donnera rien en 2015
il ya beaucoup de choses mais on a fini
les élections et que si un débat un
combat qui se mène il est tout à fait
normal que quelqu'un qui se présente dit
je suis le meilleur
c'est dit pas ça il se présente pas pour
le moment seul xavier bertrand et
françois fillon sont officiellement
candidats à cette primaire ouverte de
l'ump prévue en 2016 à roger karoutchi
comment appréciez-vous ses mots ce
nouveau positionnement de françois
fillon qui s'estime mieux placé que les
autres pour 2010 est mieux placé que qui
a oui non à la matière bien sûr que non
le sondage tailleurs sont là qu'est ce
que je vous dis on dit par exemple
ah la la regardez ce sondage qui est pas
très bon pour nicolas sarkozy il ya 54 %
des français qui disent 'tu ne regrette
pas que nicolas sarkozy ne veut pas
sauf que 54% des français mais 94% des
sympathisants de l'ump regrette 94% des
sympathisants de l'ump peut pas dire que
dans l'électorat ump est quand même le
fondement et loyaux au bois au premier
tour peut pas dire qu'il ya un désamour
à l'égard de nicolas sarkozy
d'ailleurs quand vous faites des
sondages sur les sympathisants de l'ump
nicolas sarkozy est toujours donnée loin
devant un site pour nicolas sarkozy ça
veut dire quoi
je regarde très simplement est-ce que si
nicolas sarkozy décide de revenir
il sera obligé obligé de passer par des
primaires était d'abord moi je ne sais
pas si nicolas sarkozy décidera dans le
jeu viril et c'est lourd mais c'est lui
qui décidera si les conditions
politiques sont remplies c'est pas qu'un
élément personnel
c'est aussi dans son analyse est ce que
la gauche conduit à la catastrophe est
ce que la droite est en état de gagner
est ce que on a posé des conditions à un
accord si on a besoin de lui il faudra
bien d'un mois il décide
voilà alors ensuite il est il est le
pour moi le fédérateur naturel de la
droite et du centre
il est dans les sondages sur l'autre
fillon oui pourquoi oui ben pourquoi
d'abord parce que il a déjà gagné une
présidentielle a perdu aussi oui c'est
vrai de peu et on était tous avec lui y
compris sans soin fillon d'argentins
françois fillon dire aujourd'hui rupture
quand vous avez cinq ans le premier
ministre
la république dire moi je voudrais un
projet de rupture mais de rupture donc
par rapport à la politique qu'il a lui
même sur certains employés nicolas
sarkozy à l'égard de jacques chirac
n'est pas premier ministre de jacques
chirac
il avait été miné c'est vrai mais il
était en rupture sur une période longue
je ne dis pas attendait 1,6 nicolas
sarkozy disait pour des raisons
multiples je ne reviens pas françois
fillon serait l'un des mieux placés
incontestablement donc il a raison de
jouer sa carte et sa chance puisque
comme on ne sait pas si nicolas sarkozy
revient pas forcément françois fillon
doit s'affirmer et avoir une identité ce
qui pouvait il est dans une situation
compliquée pour lui qu'est ce qui
pourrait empêcher son retour aujourd'hui
de nicolas sarkozy à sarkozy lui même
c'est à dire que je pense que c'est pas
les bisbilles qu'on essaie
maladroitement des affaires de mettre en
avant pour dire il ya ait kaci major a
compris on a vu pour la faire
bettencourt est maintenant le non lieu
donc c'est pas ça c est ce que ayant
beaucoup donné il l'intérieur de
l'économie prises à la république ayant
mené le combat et a été battue même si
ces deux peu est-ce que y considère
qu'il est indispensable qu'il revienne
pour assurer l'alternance
s'il pense que quelqu'un peut le faire
mieux et gagner il se dira pourquoi on
veut le 18 mai voilà tant parmi les
candidats possibles il ya aussi françois
fillon et maxime la sarkozie si jamais
ils ne venaient pas et ne souhaitait pas
en tout cas y aller il y aurait aussi
d'autres personnages bertrand xavier
bertrand l'a déjà dit qu'il est candidat
au alain juppé il doit se dire après
tout si il faut quelqu'un qui apaise
quelqu'un qui est un peu au dessus
pourquoi pas et d'ailleurs entre nous
soit dit c'est un homme d'état de très
grande qualité donc pourquoi pas jean
françois copé sera probablement
également tenté par la primaire ouverte
si nicolas sarkozy n'en revenait pas lui
a dit très clairement si nicolas sarkozy
revient je serai avec lui donc si
nicolas sarkozy re des copains ne serait
pas candidat aux primaires y
soutiendrait nicolas sarkozy
mais si nicolas sarkozy ne revient pas à
côté
toute sa place dans la primaire ouverte
et puis à ce moment là les choses se
feront si nicolas sarkozy ne revient pas
il y aura des reclassements et un sens
inverse
si nicolas sarkozy annonce et surtout
bien des gens qui aujourd'hui disent je
suis pour untel ou untel se reclasse
serait derrière nicolas sarkozy
alors on poursuit avec mardi et ce coup
d'éclat à l'assemblée nationale par les
députés ump claque la porte de la
commission d' enquête sur la sphère
cahuzac il boycotte la remise du rapport
et organise un point presse quelques
heures plus tôt pour dire leur colère
pour l'ump les questions qui dérangent
on était tout simplement évacués du
rapport marion lefebvre
valérie brochard l'image est inédite
christian jacob entouré par tous les
membres ump de la commission denquête
sur la sphère cahuzac
à quelques heures de l'adoption du
rapport il tente un coup d'éclat nous
avons décidé groupe ump de ne pas
cautionner cette mascarade
on est véritablement dans un mode de
fonctionnement qui qui affaiblit pour ne
pas dire qui humilie le parlement
mascarade
le mot est lancé il va résonner toute la
journée dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
l'opposition rejette en bloc les
conclusions du rapport et puisque la
commission denquête n'a pas pu
auditionner le premier ministre les
députés ump ont décidé de l'interpeller
dans l'hémicycle monsieur le premier
ministre
une question résume toutes les autres
avez vous oui ou non participer à une
réunion le 16 janvier à l'elysée en
présence de françois hollande et de
jérôme cahuzac pour décider de l'enquêté
administrative qui devait blanchir ce
dernier en brisant la muraille de chine
cette affaire a commencé par un parjure
éviter qu aujourd'hui et ne s'achève
devant l'assemblée nationale par un
autre parjure la parole est à monsieur
alain vidal et jean marc ayrault refuse
de répondre
c'est précisément cette impossibilité
d'interroger le chef du gouvernement qui
divise les députés de la commission
que savait le premier ministre et le
président de la république du compte en
suisse de jérôme cahuzac
alors là nous avons
divergence avec le rapporteur nous notre
thèse c'est que alors que le président
disposait de la république disposait dès
le mois de décembre 2012 informations
mettant en doute les affirmations
répétées d'innocence de jérôme cahuzac
est bien le président n'a pas mis fin à
ses fonctions ministérielles
il faut pas inverser les choses qui
détenait la preuve ce n'était pas les
membres du gouvernement ou l'état le
président et le rapporteur de la
commission d' enquête ce ne sont pas
d'accord sur les responsabilités de
l'appareil d'état ni l'ump ni lui d in
il est vert n'ont adopté le rapport qui
sera rendu public le 15 octobre prochain
alors roger karoutchi beaucoup de tulle
au sujet de ce rapport mais quel
peut-être vraiment le rôle d'une
commission denquête quand la justice
enquête en même temps sur la même
affaire c'est toujours le problème
heures on essaye d'éviter d'ailleurs la
création de commission denquête lorsque
la justice enquête déjà parce que on
sait que à plusieurs reprises la réponse
des autorités ou des jambes convoqué
c'est de dire secret de l'instruction je
peux pas
donc il ya des limites à la commission
d' enquête dans cette affaire je sais
pas si c'est l'enquète judiciaire qui a
beaucoup j'étais aussi c'est le fait que
l'appareil d'état n'a pas voulu
totalement répondre cette réunion dont
on parle le mois de janvier avec
françois hollande
elle n'a pas été découverte par don de
dire dans le canard enchaîné ou non je
crois c'est monsieur moscovici qui dit
devant la commission il ya eu une
réunion dans le bureau du président
république avec le premier ministre
trace donc ça n'a pas été bien fait non
si mais moi j'aurais trouvé normal que
le premier ministre aille s'expliquer
dire voilà comment ça s'est passé voilà
pourquoi etc
si vous voulez le refus de répondre la
manière d'ambrosio moscovici c'est quand
même beaucoup écouté c'est la remise du
rapport pour les députés ump vous
appelez ça donne une bonne image du
parlement tout ça je sais pas si c'est
une bonne image du parlement aussi ce
sont les limites des commission denquête
pas ce que ça veut quand même dire que
lorsque les autorités de l'état refuse
de répondre
le parlement est assez qu'elle ne peut
être attendre un tout petit peu quitte à
revoir la formulation de ces rubans de
connexions qu'il eût fallu que on laisse
faire d'abord la justice et qu'ensuite
on est une analyse plus politique
mais le débat politique est là la vérité
c'est que bon c'est pas la peine de
faire un dessin très probablement les
plus hautes autorités de l'état avaient
des doutes à défaut de certitudes au
moins des doutes sur les comptes de
monsieur cahuzac
est ce qu'ils auraient dû plutôt par des
décisions probablement oui on change de
sujet roger karoutchi nous sommes
toujours mardi direction forbach en
moselle pour manuel valls le ministre
l'intérieur par dans une tournée qu'on
m'a qualifié d'anti front national kamya
campo santo petite balade au marché
quelques poignées de main manuel valls
s'invite à forbach en moselle première
étape d'un tour de france
le rôle d'un ministre de l'intérieur
rôle de l'état et forces de l'ordre
c'est de s'attaquer à la délinquance à
l'insécurité cambriolage à la violence
aux incivilités bref à ce qui gêne
pourrit la vie des gens et notamment
dans des territoires où il ya beaucoup
de gens modestes qui souffrent déjà de
la crise derrière le discours officiel
une visite stratégique selon le front
national forbach c'est le terrain de
florian philippot c'est ici que le
numéro deux du fn se présente aux
municipales
il fait même une tournée j'ai cru
comprendre anti fn électorale sur les
fonds du ministère de l'intérieur au
passage pour soutenir un parti
socialiste en mode panique en pleine
affolement parce qu'ils voient la
dégringolade
et il voit la dynamique très très forte
sur le terrain notamment à forbach du
front national du rassemblement bleu
marine et de ma candidature
une tournée anti fn l'entourage du
ministre de l'intérieur dément mais au
sénat du côté de l'ump
le parallèle avec les résultats du parti
d'extrême droite à brignoles est vite
établi il ya déjà comme une forme
d'affolement faire une petite élection
cantonale à brignoles
gliese le gouvernement le premier
ministre en tête et un peu de temps de
ministre va aller maintenant à la
rencontre des populations pour dire mais
non mais non en rendormez vous bonnes
gens tout ça n'existe pas je pense que
d'abord c'est une politique à courte vue
et deuxièmement encore une fois ce n'est
pas de communication dont les français
ont besoin ils ont besoin de résultats
des critiques qui ne freine pas manuel
valls
fort de son bon score dans les sondages
d'opinion il compte se rendre à calais
notamment pour parler cette fois
immigration à cette visite de manuel
valls a donc eu lieu après le scrutin de
brignoles on va s'arrêter sur cette
percée du fn à ce que tu as marqué aussi
par un fort taux d'abstention c'est le
zoom de l'hebdo roland cayrol est avec
nous pour l'analyse bonjour rôle vous
êtes ce politologue
consultant pour la chaîne parlementaire
ce scrutin pour vous at-il une résonance
nationale ou faut-il au contraire le
voir à l'échelle locale à brignoles dans
le sud-est où le fn a déjà fait de bons
scores depuis de longues années
depuis deux républiques et donc des
décennies les gens qui commentent les
élections partielles disent
régulièrement des sottises et ça fait
partie des lois du genre donc évidemment
une élection partielle et surtout
cantonales partielles ça n'est qu'une
cantonales partielles pensée dans ce
canton de brignoles on a déjà voté deux
fois en 2011 2012 on a été annulé deux
fois on est chaque fois près de 50 50 et
dans chaque fois ce que le front
national qui fait soit 49 soit 51 le
voilà à 40 dans un premier tour et ça
fait trembler la france
alors voilà ça n'est que ça c'est l'un
des cantons où le front national le plus
fort en france
il confirme ça la nouveauté mais c'est
pas non plus une nouveauté dans les
partiels c'est que le parti socialiste
les partis de la majorité parlementaire
sont désavoués puisqu'ils sont ça fait
maintenant une habitude plus là où
second tour mais il n'y a pas de percée
du front national
beaucoup d'abstention il ya eu beaucoup
d'absences classique dans une partielle
il ya 2/3 d'abstention comme c'est la
loi karoutchi roland cayrol vous êtes
d'accord pour dire qu'il n'y a pas de
signal en vue des élections municipales
on peut pas tirer de conclusions
même temps il ya des signaux mais les
signaux pour le moment sont plutôt dans
les sondages les français une fraction
des français près d'un quart des
français sont tentés de dire lors on ne
sait pas si c'est j'ai décidé d'aller
voter front national aussi ses
attentions
attention je suis prêt à le faire si
vous ne me satisfaisait pas on ne sait
pas encore ce avec une déclaration de
sondages mais on n'a pas pour le moment
dans les urnes dans les faits ni dans
les adhésions au parti front national on
n'a pas de preuves
quand j'ai entendu que c'était le
premier parti en france il faut tout de
même pas exagérer à part faire des
flexions européenne voilà le problème
c'est que c'est dans une période où les
gens sont accablés d'impôt très critique
sur l'insécurité sur l'identité savent
plus où ils vont il ya cette espèce de
ras-le-bol et on y va
je peux voter front national est ce que
pour autant aux municipales avec des
listes avec des candidats soit sortant
soit pas sortant mais qu'ils connaissent
est ce que la réaction est la même bien
sûr que non donc je pense qu'en réalité
ils vivent un ami les municipales c'est
un vrai ami et y aura pas de percée du
front national aux victimes et qu'on en
fait trop autour de marine le pen est
sûre pour ceux qui à qui la faute
comedia ou politiques tout le monde tout
le monde le gouvernement qui multiplie
les textes droit de vote des étrangers
suppression des taxes sur les visas
mesures en faveur de telle ou telle
catégorie
le gouvernement pousse pas ce qui se dit
ah si ça pouvait affaiblir l'opposition
parlementaire l'opposition parlementaire
en paltrow et les médias aussi donc
toujours le jeu de l'instrumentalisation
du national bien sûr mais bien sûr que
ce soit simplement une
instrumentalisation je crois qu'il ya
une vraie un vrai effet de mode que les
médias donnent le là et on est dans un
moment où il fait beau et on dit ah
c'est bon pour le front national il
pleut c'est bon pour le front national
il ya une espèce de mode qui s'est
installé le montée irrésistible du front
national que je pense que ça risque de
finir par être vrai parce que c'est au
fond qu'il faut répondre aux gens et pas
à l'effet de mode
alors justement vous montez sur quoi au
front pour répondre à cette sur quoi
vous mais moi je suis installé à carry
brutale est prédéterminée et en même
temps j'ai évolué je le reconnais avec
la situation et la droite décomplexée
comme des ricoh pèse c'était pas
forcément au départ ma tasse de thé moi
j'étais beaucoup plus sur des consensus
et tout mais je crois que il faut dire
les choses
ce que ne supportent plus en période de
crise les gens c'est l'espèce de
dissimulation des vrais sujets les vrais
sujets c'est la délinquance les vrais
sujets 7 l'immigration clandestine a
explosé qu'on n'en peut plus les vrais
sujets c'est que l'explosion fiscale ne
peut plus être maîtrisés comme ça donc
la baisse des dépenses publiques un
meilleur contrôle de l'immigration
la remise en cause de schengen le fait
de savoir qu'est ce qu'on fait de la m e
l'aide médicale pour les les les sans
papiers
tous ces sujets là il faut les traiter
de manière républicaine s'agit pas
d'avoir des solutions excessive mais il
faut arrêter de dire maintenant on parle
surtout pas de seins parce que si on
parle de ça ça fait monter le front
national
à force de dire ça on parle de ria et
comme on parle de rien les gens disaient
mais puisqu'ils nous parle de rien on va
vers les extrêmes sur le front national
c'est thierry modo le porte parole du
groupe ps qui l'a dit aujourd'hui je
voulais juste mal
je voudrais juste que vous écoutez vous
on va réagir juste après le front
national est il ou pas un parti
d'extrême droite pensent que non
seulement c'est un parti d'extrême
droite mais que c'est même plus que ça
c'est un parti national fasciste ceux et
celles ceux et celles d'entre vous qui
en douteraient liront avec un grand
intérêt le discours de marine le pen en
clôture de l'université d'été de
marseille en lan cayrol le fn un parti
d'extrême droite au pas je crois que les
sympathisants eux mêmes du front
national lorsqu'il choisit sur une
aisselle gauche-droite sur les sondeurs
l'endroit où ils sont il se met le plus
à droite de la droite possible donc
l'extrême droite ça me paraît une
catégorie
lyon pour un politologue qui n'a rien de
scandaleux ils sont les héritiers de
cette tradition il occupe cette place
sur l'échiquier politique
évidemment quand j'entends en revanche
national fasciste
on ne voit pas ni dans les méthodes ni
dans le programme actuel du front
national ce qui pourrait dire ça aux
populistes sûrement il ya une espèce de
volonté de flatter le peuple dans ses
instincts ne pas participer à
l'éducation civique à laquelle sont dans
lequel sont tous les partis politiques
oui national fasciste et c'est ça les
sommes perçues professeur d'histoire
c'est la fois ci ça me choque parce que
ça rappelle enfin on imagine les
cohortes de s à dans les villes et on
imagine tout ce qu'on veut ou autour de
la période nazie faut pas tout mélanger
d'abord parce que ça discrédite le
propos que l'on tient si on est excessif
aujourd'hui ou alors est d'accord ça va
ça suffit donc de moi je fasse droite je
pense aujourd'hui c'est plutôt un parti
populiste qui pour préparer sa mue futur
essaye de se diaboliser y compris par
rapport à l'extrême droite est à dire
que marine le pen qui espère un jour
quand même contrairement à son père qui
espère un jour accéder au pouvoir essaye
de préparer les étapes de commandes de
venir en partie entre guillemets plus
acceptable par le fameux arc républicain
donc tout va y être elle va même refusé
extrême droite et refusera populiste
elle va dire qu'elle a des voix de
gauche et de droite
voilà donc notre combat est plus sur la
caricature des propositions que sur le
classement parce que ça n'a pas de sens
on va changer de sujet on va passer à
mercredi avec un texte très controversé
la réforme pénale a été présenté en
conseil des ministres le projet de loi
christiane taubira contient une mesure
phare pour lutter contre la récidive la
peine en milieu ouvert
autrement dit la prison à la maison un
projet fustigé par la droite
explications déterminé et imperturbable
christiane taubira défend son projet
pénale pour désengorger les prisons et
lutter contre la récidive
sa mesure phare la création d'une peine
de probation alternatives à
l'emprisonnement
elle sera effectuée en milieu ouvert
sous surveillance étroite
seuls les délits passibles de cinq ans
de prison maximum sont concernés les
crimes en sont donc exclues au coeur de
la réforme le conseiller de probation
le premier ministre a annoncé la
création d'un millier d'emplois
je rappelle qu'un millier d'emplois
c'est quand même une augmentation de 30%
du corps à milliers d'empreintes va
concerner bien entendu les conseillers
d'insertion et de probation mais
également parce que il faut pour que ça
fonctionne il faut des personnels
administratifs et techniques donc
également des personnels administratifs
qui est technique
le projet de loi prévoit aussi la
suppression des peines plancher ses
peines minimales et automatique
emblématique du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy dévoilé cet été
la réforme est très controversé objet
d'un bras de fer estivale entre
christiane taubira et son collègue
manuel valls en désaccord sur le fond
est fustigé par la droite qui y voient
un feu vert donné aux délinquants
cette réforme pénale elle est
complètement hors sol complètement hors
sol tient pas compte des victimes
contrairement à ce qui a été dit le
texte de loi sera débattue après les
élections municipales
officiellement pour cause de calendrier
chargé à l'assemblée en attendant la
ministre poursuit son tour de france
pour expliquer et défendre sa réforme
donc elle n'est toujours pas faite vous
écoutez je dire ce texte était la
priorité des prioritaires devait l'avoir
dès octobre novembre puis rap en solo là
entre valls taubira vance fils sur la
tête photo les parlementaires après les
municipales plutôt correct à valse valls
à fond les ballons mais va fort les
ballots d'un valls querelles et pouvoir
de faire pas seulement parler parce que
ça on disait tout à l'heure
quels sont les textes les mesures et
tout pour faire monter le fn enfin quand
vous dites aux jeunes dans les cités
difficiles moi j'ai été élu à nanterre
et à villeneuve la garenne dans avec des
cités difficiles quand vous leur dites
alors tous ceux qui sont communs à moins
de cinq ans ferme
ils sont dehors sincèrement les
policiers ou le fait de sortir un dealer
du secteur de la capacité d'être là
c'est déjà dans l'exemple donné aux
autres dans la sanction qui est affiché
une mesure qui est bonne pour tout le
monde et pour la vie des gens des gens
modestes pas des gens qui dans leur
hôtel particulier dans les beaux
quartiers soient pas soir les dealers
moi je suis atterré de voir ça mais en
réalité on avait deux politiques soient
construisent et les places de prison ce
que l'on roule lui offert ce que manuel
valls a débordé et puis c'est nord ces
deux visions de la société deux
idéologies qui s'affrontent
finalement non pas du tout moi je ne
considère pas être sécuritaire fou mais
que des gens ayant vraiment comme idée
parce que pour aller à cinq ans ferme
au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut pas juste
avoir volé une pomme
christiane taubira encore dit que ça
sachant qu on parle pas des peines
prévues par le code qui sont souvent
extraits très lourde mais qui ne sont
pas ou jamais atteinte à ce niveau là
par les jugements les jugements pour
arriver à cinq ans ferme
c'est que vous avez fait vraiment un bon
moi je trouve que c'est excessif dans
une société fragilisée avec des gens
inquiets avec la multiplication des
actes de délinquance l'insécurité dans
les transports dans la rue les gens ont
peur peur jeudi palisson tape est dans
la rue ça y est ils ont une kalachnikov
à la main behiels mienne quiétude
c'est un mauvais signal voilà un thème
original construisons des places de
prison
humaniser les prisons faisant en sorte
de mieux réinsérer très bien faisons de
la prévention parfait mais ne jetez pas
en pâture allez on va vous les remettre
tous dehors et bien vous débrouiller
dans la vie des quartiers
je vous propose de retourner vers
l'assemblée nationale vous avez tout ça
vous avez sûrement entendu une belle
hommes sur les banques ce soit au sénat
ou à l'assemblée quand vous étiez
ministre en charge des relations que le
parlement est ce que vous a déjà fait le
coup de la poule de la poule non j'ai eu
parfois pire mais ces limitations sur
les sur les bords évidemment vous l'avez
entendu d'un élu ump qui a limité le
captage d'une poule pendant
l'intervention d'une élue écologiste
véronique massenot écoutez je ne le nie
pas mais il est nécessaire de voir au
delà de ce critère l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé notamment
ça suffit mais qui sait qu'ici j'ai pas
une poule c'est bon il ya des
comportements du royaume des cotisations
et de 35 ans pour les femmes alors l'élu
concerné a écopé de sanctions
financières pour un mois pour vous c'est
du machisme ou c'est de la bêtise
moi je vais vous dire lorsque j'étais au
gouvernement chargé avec le parlement
j'avais eu des entretiens avec jean marc
ayrault à l'époque présidente du groupe
socialiste et avec d'autres d'ailleurs
pour dire franchement
l'image donnée par l'assemblée plus par
d'oran qui passe parce que je sais la
terre plus par l'assemblée que par le
sait
séance de questions peut être un peu
brutal mais pas à ce point mais l'image
pas bonne enfin l'opinion publique se
dit qu'est ce que c'est que ce carnaval
on étend la crise
on est tous en train de dire quelles
sont les solutions pour l'emploi et tout
s'est tu et ils voient ça c'est spes de
spectacles souvent infligeant où les
gens s'insultent où les gens se méprise
on peut faire de la jeune et beau dire
qu'ils changent mais oui mais parce que
j'allais presque dire il faut que dans
chaque groupe politique dans chaque
parti politique
les gens nous attendaient vous pouvez
vous opposer fermement à vos adversaires
politiques ne pas d' insulte pas
d'injures pas de mépris ouvert pas de
cris déplacés ont fait ça parce que là
il faut passer à la télé à est ce qu'on
a vu est ce que j'ai fait et je trouve
ça désolant pour la démocratie parce que
tout le monde parce que la gauche droite
sincèrement vous avez des héros du 15
heures la key qui se reconnaîtront parce
que eh oui oui les bains wc etc et qui
arrivent et qui se disent vous allez
voir je vais faire le spectacle pour
qu'on me voit à défaut d'idées hurlant
je trouve ça affligeant
je pense qu'on peut dire prenez des
mesures beaucoup plus fort sur prévu je
suis désolé de vous le dire
le règlement interne l'assemblée comme
le réglementaire du sénat prévoit des
mesures progressives qui sont fortes
sauf que c'est aux présidents doivent
décider ça leur ferait quelques exemples
ça s'arrêterait alors on va passer à
jeudi on va parler des retraites avec là
encore un peu de cacophonie dans le vote
erreur ou actes manqués un des articles
clés de la réforme des retraites a été
purement supprimée huit députés
socialistes ont voté contre l'article 4
qui visait à décaler la date de
revalorisation des pensions au 1er
octobre une erreur de vote rectifier
mais qui a suffit à semer le désordre
dans l'hémicycle rim des dameurs coup
théâtre à l'assemblée mercredi soir à la
surprise générale à 44 voix contre 39
les députés supprime le report de six
mois de la revalorisation annuelle des
retraites c'était l'un des articles les
plus controversés du projet de loi
problème il s'agirait d'une simple
erreur de vote de certains députés
socialistes au total huit d'entre eux
affirment s'être trompé j'ai le
sentiment que le résultat du vote et
hier soir est une trahison du réel vote
que j'ai voulu effectuer et que j'ai
fait corrigé hier et dès l'ouverture la
séance ne bruisse que de cette erreur
marisol touraine demande leur vote de
cet article il ya donc une erreur qui va
être réparé le gouvernement demandera
qu'il y ait une nouvelle délibération
sur cet article ce qui se fait de façon
très classique mais à l'évidence la
droite cherche à instrumentaliser ce qui
s'est passé à transformer un incident
technique en difficulté politique elle a
choisi une tactique de l'obstruction la
décision passe très mal auprès des
autres groupes
aujourd'hui dire qu'il s'agit d'une
erreur de manipulation dire que huit
voix socialistes c'est à dire même avec
le couplage que quatre députés aient pu
se tromper
je dis que c'est véritablement un dessin
donné à dénis au vote des parlementaires
cette nuit pour continuer à vouloir
massacrer les
les retraités et baisser leurs pensions
mousser c'est vraiment de l'acharnement
madame la ministre
ici vous espérer arriver à tordre le
bras décollé qui ont voté avec nous hier
qui d'ailleurs ce matin ne sont pas là
peut-être qu'ils ont été assignés à
résidence
les députés continuent les discussions
autour de la création du compte
pénibilité dans une ambiance qui
s'annonce tendu angers car aussi ça vous
est arrivé alors ainsi doctement que
quand on fait une erreur de vote
si vous en avez un ou deux il peut y
avoir des erreurs de vote 8 surtout
suffit toujours pas grand monde 1 c de
qualité ça là c'est l'acte manqué c'est
à dire qu'en réalité ils ont été dans le
débat convaincu qu'il fallait pas voter
une mesure extrêmement négatives pour
les retraités ils sont nés moi dans ma
circuit fait engueuler si je vote une
mesure où je dis aux retraités on va
faire les dents et on dit alors moi je
compte je veux pas de ça puis le
lendemain comme le parti le gouvernement
vous êtes tombé sur la tête en disant
ouais inadmissible regarde dans quelle
situation tu nous mais on s'en sort
comme on peut en disant que peut-être
pas bien vu ce que j'ai fait mais c'est
pas moi parce que peut-être que j'avais
donné procuration mais bon enfin
d'accord c'est alors la deuxième
délibération et de droit donc ça la
ministre a raison sur le fond mais ça en
dit long sur le fait que le groupe
socialiste va dans ce débat sur les
retraites et va voter ce texte avec
vraiment si on pouvait avoir déboulé sur
les pieds et si au bout et ne pas le
faire vous voyez pas le faire par décret
sans nous ce serait mieux si on ne font
quand même il ya des avancées à la
création sur quoi sur linas création de
ce conte pénibilité de la jouabilité
tout mon temps passé très loin des
années aussi on l'a voulu le faire aussi
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
serait un progrès par rapport à
précédente réforme de l'église n'ont
rien fait du tout c'est une fausse
réforme c'est une non aux réformes
on vous dit ah ben voilà on va passer à
43 ans alors dans quatre ans pour le
reste on touche pas à l'âge légal
de la retraite ce qui est quand même
l'élément le plus lourd en vrai voilà
dans une réforme
si on veut équilibrer les comptes
on n'y peut rien et c'est tant mieux
nous gagnons entre deux et trois mois de
vie supplémentaires chaque année
l'accord total sur l'allongement
sur-le-champ pense alors il ya la jda
l'astre il faut que ce soit 63 64 ans ou
65 ans il a eu un débat moi je pense que
dire tout de suite 65 quand on a une
démographie meilleurs que nos voisins
tant qu'à faire au moins que ce soit un
avantage ça nous coûte suffisamment d'un
côté parce qu'on a une politique
familiale faut pas non plus que ça coûte
de tous les côtés donc si c'est une
force joue dessus
moi je pense que faut pas aller sur la
symbolique si on peut dire
progressivement d'ici 2020 2009 au delà
2025 2030
il faut arriver à 63 64 ans allons-y
mais c'est surtout sur la durée de
cotisation ou il faut dire attendez
c'est pas raisonnable de dire on va
gagner 15 ans de cotisations en plus
deux en dix ans c'est pas possible
si on veut dire 63 64 ans alors très
bien ballon pas 65 mais accroît son la
durée de cotisation plus rapidement
et puis trouvant des solutions sur la
pénibilité bien sûr sur les gens qui ont
commencé très tôt bien sûr mais en même
temps il faut bien un équilibre moi je
vais vous dire cette loi sur les
retraites c'est sait rien et dans trois
ans je vous garantis gauche droite au
pouvoir
il faudrait de nouveaux textes on a très
exactement
pour finir vous connaissez des 10 et oui
un petit peu pas où vous y emmène cellou
diallo bon si vous m'y emmener
alors on mai dernier sortait sur vos
écrans le film le pouvoir un
documentaire sur la plongée au coeur de
l'elysée avec un homme principal
évidemment françois hollande en prime la
sortie du dvd et des bonus s'estimant
barbarie qui vous explique tout ça on
avait quitté françois hollande sur les
marches de l'elysée dans le documentaire
le pouvoir de pierre favier et patrick
rotman sorti en salles en mai dernier le
film est disponible en dvd ce mois ci
avec en supplément une deuxième version
intitulée à l'elysée sans oublier les
bonus un entretien inédit de françois
hollande ou encore la scène intégrale de
son discours à ses collaborateurs moi ce
que je vous demande c'est d'avoir des
notes qu'ils fassent une page deux pages
au maximum
il faut que tout soit résumé tous soient
concentrées en une page ou deux îles qui
ne doivent pas être des pages où on
explique c'est les pages qui prépare un
décision à la manière d'un que sais-je
que l'on pourrait croire destiné aux
élèves de l'ena le film à l'elysée donne
cette fois ci la parole aux proches
conseillers de santé comprend également
l'agenda parlementaire puisque c'est lui
qui structurent la vie politique de la
france un des différents projets de loi
on prend tout ça et à partir de tout ça
on essaye d'organiser quand on peut à un
calendrier sur trois quatre cinq et je
vous dis si possible jusqu'aux à se
mettre souvent techniques parfois
rébarbatif l'exercice du pouvoir au t2
toute référence politique chez nous
laisse sur notre faim
la description de la sphère élyséenne
devient alors contemplative voire
superficiel
les dorures du palais les salons feutrés
et les huissiers méticuleux laisse une
impression désuète une illustration de
l' isolement du pouvoir que françois
hollande essaie de tempérer dans
l'entretien inédit moi j'accepte que les
français le parent librement
parfois me demande une photo un
autographe
je laisse finalement libre si les
français d'aller jusqu'à moi pour
l'instant ils le font pas pacifiquement
malgré des huit mois passés dans les
couloirs du palais et les 50 jours de
tournage cette version complète des
coulisses du pouvoir reste plus proche
d'une journée du patrimoine à l'elysée
coût du scoop médiatique verdict roger
karoutchi vous avez vu le document rien
je trouve que sincèrement d'accord mais
non mais si c'est une visite historique
patrimonial très bien mais d'abord
l'exercice du pouvoir
il se passe dans les caméras télé donc
toutes ces réunions fils mais c'est du
pipeau intégral chacun sait qu'il doit
pas dépasser d'un millimètre qui doit
dire bon donc c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe
la décision et se prend à quelques-uns
elle se penchera au téléphone elle se
pense ou vendre un contact direct avec
le président avec le directeur de
cabinet ou avec le secrétaire général
vous n'avez pas tout ce cinéma avec
tarantino qui viennent faire des notes
d'une page assez rigolo mais tape sur
deuxième élément voir le président la
république actuel dire aux belles et
français moi je veux bien qu'il fasse
une photo avec moi d'abord ya de moins
en moins de monde car veut et deuxième
élément ils viennent vers moi pour le
moment pacifiquement et heureusement
qu'il n'y ait pour le moment
enfin bon jeu que je vous dise oui
complètement
vous savez quand en 2006 pendant la
campagne présidentielle nicolas sarkozy
mme diriger une excellente idée
il faut en finir avec les isolements
débit ni du pouvoir etc
on va faire deux tours il y aura une
tour pour l'exécutif
on mettra tous les ministères et toutes
en haut on mettra le président la
république comme ça on se verra tous
tous les jours
et puis de l'autre côté on fera une tôt
pour le parlement et on met à côté l'un
à l'autre comme ça tous les pouvoirs
seront regroupés et les gens seront pas
isolé c'est un feu zappa ce que les gens
aiment les palettes ou et puis pis pour
recevoir les étrangers tout c'est mieux
mais d'un autre côté savez cette espèce
de volonté de dire il faut sortir de ça
et c'est vrai que le pouvoir
les palais nationaux c'est bien par
rapport à l'image laisse idol eh bien on
va terminer sur cette action merci
beaucoup
roger karoutchi d'arrêter notre invité
restez sur les chaînes parlementaires à
la semaine prochaine au revoir au revoir